foreign
ER is with us in Canada hey olamar how
are you
good how are you better than I deserve
how can we help
uh well
um I'm actually ecstatic to be on this
phone call I can't believe I'm talking
to you guys but
um I'm calling from New Brunswick Canada
uh I actually moved with my family and
my two babies three and four from
Toronto escaping pretty much what was
happening over there a normal rundown
home was two million dollars we didn't
want to get into a mortgage like that
and because we had the freedom of uh
remote jobs we decided Well let's move
uh we wanted a more conservative place
as well so it's been amazing living here
but we purchased a house four hundred
thousand dollars last year uh it has
been a year and a half
and I feel like I'm on baby step number
zero
we are reading the book and we're doing
everything we can but we had a very bad
advice with our mortgage we went on a
variable rate last year and I just I
feel hopeless I don't know
how to even care through this so we've
done what we can and we got the book
from the church
um Total Money Makeover we've been
reading it but with two little ones it's
been tough and I just I don't know how
to deal and cope with
I guess paying the mortgage when we
initially budget it for sixteen hundred
dollars and we ended up at a fixed rate
of actually we fixed the rate last week
and we ended up at 3 200. so you have a
three thousand two hundred dollar
mortgage and what is your income
uh so my husband makes 85 000 a year and
I recently started out a work uh with
the same company actually and I'm making
33.90 uh I'm not on payroll but I am
I've been with them for 10 months and
they are willing to put me on payroll
it's just it hasn't come to that yet
it's 33.90 an hour or 33 900 a year
no 30 so
3390 monthly plus
um 85 000 a year that my husband earns
which is I believe it's 4 900. a month
so we're roughly around the 8 000 to
almost nine thousand dollars no you're
about 8 500 a month to take home but and
you have a three thousand two hundred
dollar mortgage which leaves five
thousand dollars to pay the rest of your
bills why can you not do that
better home last year
we had a I don't know why we came up
with a bright idea that we wanted to
finish the basement that we had in this
house because we wanted to rent it out
we said well maybe let's do like a side
uh income and have
um someone be downstairs so is it
finished or not
it is okay somebody living down there I
didn't finish it yeah finally okay and
how much are they paying you
twelve hundred dollars okay and so
that's another 1200 on the 8 500. now
what what are the bills have you got
other than the thirty two hundred
dollars what are the debt payments have
you got
uh insurance I believe is 240. no I'm
talking about debt and debt oh it's that
it's um
000 on a home credit line how much is
the payment on that
uh a lot just like 900 1100 or maybe
because we really got the high yeah okay
1100 all right so that's 42 4300 okay
and what else yeah uh twenty thousand on
a credit card which I I don't know how
it even came to that okay
here's what's going on okay your brain
is scrambled eggs on this money stuff
because it's you're all over the place
just to talk to you and that's where all
your stress is coming from
okay so the numbers you've given me
because you haven't thrown me any
numbers here that don't work
you've got ninety seven hundred dollars
a month coming into this house counting
the 1200 rent
okay the only numbers you've given me
are thirty two hundred and Eleven
Hundred going out
so when you just start right just get
done no no no no no my turn just at the
top of the page write nine thousand
seven hundred dollars and then write
minus thirty two hundred minus 1100
minus a little for insurance minus some
electricity and food and then I then
you're gonna go Hey where's all my dad
gum money going because that's where I'm
going right now I can't figure out why
you're stressed out about this you
should have plenty of money so what that
tells me is you guys are very
disorganized
you're very chaotic it's chaotic talking
to you I'm not being mean to you but
that's the that's what's happening it's
the stresses in the air I can feel it
and and honey you got to get this you
guys got to get if you if when you push
this down on the paper and transfer this
financial stress into actual arithmetic
the stress will start to dissipate
because you you are not out of control
here unless you've left out entire
segments in this conversation which is
possible but uh you've got there's
something about writing it down
that makes it come alive and makes it
get under control so RMR it's kind of
like
remember that time back in high school
Ken when you have a problem or you might
do it as an adult and you sit down and
with your friend who's going to help you
the problem and you tell them the whole
problem and by the time you actually put
it into cogent words you know the answer
and it's not a problem anymore your
friend doesn't have to say anything they
just got to look at you like you're an
idiot right and so
um or worse than that you write it down
if you write yourself a report on what's
going on by the time your brain goes
from jumble to verbal and then one more
step from verbal to written you have
processed this information very
thoroughly and the answer oftentimes
will appear right in front of you you're
on the other end of that Spectrum right
now Lorimar so you guys need a budget
that's what you need and your your time
is not being managed well your kids are
overrunning you things are I bet your
house is a mess
and so you know the chaos that's in the
air and when you get things orderly and
straightened up the calendar straight
the budget is straight you're going to
get on top of this and you're gonna be
able to run it's so fast because you're
really doing better than it feels like
you're doing to you
your numbers are not nearly as bad as
your emotions are telling you they are
yeah what I heard is someone who's being
reactive instead of proactive and the
power in writing it down and creating
this budget Omar what Dave's telling you
is right when you look at just that
exercise where he said all right let's
start with what's coming in you guys
have got to write down what's going out
and when you begin to get intentional
proactive versus reactive you guys are
letting every day come at you and I
don't think you have a plan at all
your emotions are meant not your logic
that's right so get your critical
thinking skills up on top of it yeah
open up an every dollar app get that
thing going
um you've got to know you've got a Total
Money Makeover book you and your husband
sit down turn the TV off put the kids to
bed tell them to stay in bed yeah and
we're going to sit here we're going to
read this book and we're gonna freaking
do these steps exactly we're gonna get
these forms out of the back of the book
even I don't care if you do it longhand
with a yellow Pad but when you get
organized you will feel more in control
and the reason you feel that way is
because you are more in control yeah and
it changes everything folks when you
jump on your every dollar app and do
your budget for the first time you say
this is how much is coming in and here's
where I know it's going and then there's
this big pile of money left over
you're gonna go what am I doing
I'm spending like I'm in Congress
what am I doing
you're gonna have that moment where you
feel like you got a raise it's true
every dollar allows you to see where you
are and then you can start making
changes but the problem is when you
don't know where you are and what we
felt in her was this I just don't know
where any of it's going and I don't know
and I don't know and here's what we know
about just human psychology when the
scariest thing is the unknown and so
every dollar allows me to actually for
the first time go oh that's where I'm
spending money bad news is not nearly as
scary as unknown that is so true the
human brain reacts more aggressively and
positively towards bad news than it does
the unknown you might have cancer it's
going to be three weeks before you tell
you that's three weeks of hell yeah and
then they say you got stage three bring
on the chemo you're like at least I know
what it is the devil I know let's fight
it here we go game on but the unknown
will drive you bananas
this is the Ramsay show